[MUSIC PLAYING]
The way we walk can tell us
just as much about our health,
as our pulse or blood pressure.
Professor Katabi's
group at MIT CSAIL
can now measure a person's
walking speed continuously
and non-intrusively
with a device
called WiGait by sending
low radiation wireless
signals that reflect
off of a person's body
and back to the device.
WiGait can measure different
people's walking speeds
with 95% to 99% accuracy.
WiGait could help detect
injuries or health issues,
like cognitive decline
or cardiac disease
and does so while anonymizing
your data as nothing
more than a dot on a screen.
WiGait first distinguishes
walking from other movements,
like reading or cleaning and
then uses a special signal
processing algorithms
to distinguish
between different
walking speeds.
WiGait is also 85% to
99% accurate at measuring
a person's stride-length
which could allow researchers
to better understand conditions
like Parkinson's disease
that are characterized
by reduced step size.
In the future, the researchers
hope to test the system
on people with disabilities
like Parkinson's, multiple
sclerosis, or Alzheimer's.
[MUSIC PLAYING]